china no es la bala de plata de Rusia
contra las sanciones económicas de
occidente en la real es que por más que
Pekín y Moscú hayan estrechado su
cooperación económica en Las dos últimas
décadas sin esta muy lejos de igualar la
relevancia de la Unión Europea para el
comercio ruso la Unión Europea recibe el
33% de las exportaciones rusas mientras
china apenas el 15% esa problemática
queda resumida en el gas china recibe
apenas una quinta parte del gas que va a
parar hacia Europa y los últimos
acuerdos entre Pekín y Moscú exigirán la
construcción de nuevas infraestructuras
costosísimas que más tardarán varios
años en ser completadas así que el
escenario mejor para Rusia es a medio
plazo vender solo una porción del gas
que envía hacia Europa y además mucho
más barato No parece el plan perfecto
improbable que quiera porque saltarse
las sanciones económicas de occidente
podría provocar que también china
quedara sujeta a ellas y en todo este
conflicto ucraniano la máxima prioridad
de China es no deteriorar las relaciones
tanto políticas como económicas con la
Unión Europea